retrouvez nous sommes ensemble pendant
deux heures deux heures en direct avec
vous on va prendre le temps d'analyser
de questionner toute l'actualité
politique parlementaire mais aussi
international vous allez le voir
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour ce nouveau numéro
de votre émission les matins du sénat où
vous allez être plongés au coeur des
travaux de la haute assemblée
[Musique]
vous
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
manger c'est voter vous l'avez compris
nous sommes sur la côte normande à re
manche à l'emplacement même où les
alliés débarquaient en 1944 pour sauver
le monde libre de la barbarie nazie
justement nous allons rencontrer des
hommes et des femmes qui dans une forme
de résistance continue à se battre pour
préserver un mode d'agriculture des
traditions et savoir faire alimentaire
qui nous permettent de nous protéger de
la malbouffe d'avoir cet échange
je n'étais donc pas être trop long dans
l'intervention liminaire pour pouvoir
répondre à l'ensemble des questions qui
seront posées au fond je vis là
concentré autour de trois enjeux la
question je crois que cette audition est
de savoir comment est ce que la crise du
coronavirus aract et les différents
secteurs
j'ai la responsabilité au gouvernement
et comment est-ce que nous avons répondu
à cet impact pour évidemment à protéger
des structures et l'ensemble des
missions qu'elle porte et donc je vais
articulé mama mon propos en avant
d'abord la question de la vie
associative puis la question de la
jeunesse et enfin la question de
l'engagement cilic sur la vie
associative vous l'avez dit madame la
présidente
un secteur absolument central dans notre
pays à la fois pour les missions qui
sont accomplis pour le lien social
éducation à la citoyenneté qui a porté
par les structures associatives aussi
pour des raisons économiques 10% du pays
des 1,5 g parmi les moins de salariés
des emplois qui sont par principe non
délocalisables et donc un secteur
extrêmement important et central dans
l'économie de notre pays
aussi et comme les entreprises comme
l'ensemble des structures de droite
aider les associations était très
impacté par la crise du corona us pas le
confinement
l'essentiel des activités des
associations ont dû être stoppées du
fait du confinement a été suspendue ce
qui a évidemment un impact un impact
très fort un certain nombre d'annoncés
de l'association ont poursuivi leurs
activités parce qu'elle est absolument
essentielle et vitale dans ce contexte
ans notamment aux associations de l'aide
alimentaire et de la solidarité
d'urgence est au fond la préoccupation a
été immédiatement
après l'annnonce du confinement de
réunir les réseaux associatifs et
d'identifier avec eux les difficultés
qui allaient se manifester pour la
première difficulté qui a été a été mise
en avant est évidemment une difficulté
d'ordre économique qui dit confirmant la
suspension des activités dit perte de
recettes de cotisations de recettes
liées à des événements d'il
interrogations sur des subventions qui
devaient être versés pour des projets
qui n'ont pu se tenir du fait du
continent et des interrogations sur la
capacité à maintenir des salariés dans
la structure au moment où ses recettes
sont mises en suspens qui m'a amené très
rapidement a annoncé que l'ensemble des
dispositifs de droit commun qui était
mis en place pour les entreprises serait
accessible aux associations je pense
évidemment à la question du chômage
partiel
accessible aux associations je pense aux
prêts garantis par l'état vous évoquez
résidente la difficulté pour des
associations qui avait une trésorerie
qui ne dépassait pas les 3 mois l'accès
aux prêts garantis par l'état et quidams
on a permis d'y répondre
et puis au fond de solidarité auxquelles
les associations ont également accès je
reviens pas aussi sur les possibilités
de reports de charges de loyer qui
évidemment leur ont été lors ont été une
vraie interrogation a été levée à
émerger des acteurs associatifs sur la
question des subventions que j'évoquais
à l'instant puisque vous savez que
certainement un grand nombre de
subventions sont reconditionnés liées à
la tenue de projets la tenue
d'événements et du fait du confinement
grand nombre de ces événements n'ont pu
se tenir il y avait une interrogation
très forte sur une chouette pour les
pouvoirs publics d'honorer les
subventions y compris pour des projets
qui ne pouvait se tenir
moi j'ai défendu très tôt et obtenu que
pour ce qui est de l'état
l'ensemble des subventions qui avait été
rappelé qu'il avait été décidé soit
versée aux associations indépendamment
de la tenue des projets pour lesquels
ces subventions devaient être versées
parce que évidemment ces subventions
elles viennent financer un projet très
concrète et on sait qu'elles sont aussi
budget dé par les associations dans leur
équilibre global et dans leur capacité à
pérenniser alors
leur structure et donc il était
absolument essentiel que ces subventions
soient versés les deux exemples que j'ai
pris d'abord une très grosse association
solidarité sida qui organise chaque
année le festival solidays et qui reçoit
pour ça une subvention de l'état ne peut
organiser son festival cette année
elle recevra quand même la subvention de
l'état qui était prévu et pour des
exemples de plus petites associations
qui sont soutenus par des parents on
peut prendre des associations
environnementales qui organise au moment
du printemps le décompte des espèces par
exemple qu'ils reçoivent pour cela des
subventions de l'ademe qui n'ont pas pu
effectuer ses activités là mais qui
recevront aussi quand même les
subventions qui est qui était prévue
bien d'interrogations en tout cas
l'association continuera à poser la
question du maintien des subventions des
collectivités locales dans des échanges
que j'ai eus avec les associations
d'élus
il semble que le souhait est évidemment
de maintenir c'est ces subventions parce
que comme collectivités locales pouvoir
bénéficier d'associations qui tiennent
debout qui survivent à cette crise
évidemment aussi essentiel mais a bien
évidemment je profite de cette audition
pour passer aussi le message aux
collectivités locales pour qu'elles
puissent embrayé sur ce mouvement que
nous avons impulsé de maintien et de
garantie des subventions quand bien même
des projets n'auraient pu se tenir
le deuxième enjeu très fort qui a été
soulevée par les associations et là je
parle notamment des associations qui ont
maintenu leurs activités c'est la
question la ressource bénévoles on sait
que nos associations ont la chance de
pouvoir bénéficier de bénévoles en
nombre vous avez rappelé les chiffres et
qu'une grande partie de ces bénévoles
sont des personnes âgées bien souvent
retraités qui ont du temps pour pour
cela est évidemment la crise du
coronavirus le confinement a conduit
beaucoup d'associations par des
associations avec beaucoup de
responsabilité a demandé à leurs
bénévoles l'accord des relais tout a
démarré alors des vols les plus âgées de
rester chez eux pour ne pas s'exposer un
dut coronavirus aux mairies ans pour des
associations qui ont dû absolument
central dans cette crise et dans sa
dimension sociale je pense encore une
fois aux associations d aide alimentaire
de solidarité ça a été un vrai
la difficulté au départ dans les
premiers jours du confinement des points
de distribution des banques alimentaires
des restos du coeur du secours populaire
n'ont pas pu ouvrir faute de bénévoles
les bénévoles de plus de 70 ans c'est un
tiers des bénévoles réguliers des restos
du coeur par exemple donc il y avait
cette difficulté de ressources bénévoles
ce qui m'a conduit à lancer la réserve
civique en cohérence avec le message qui
avait été adressée par le président de
la république aux français d'affronter
cette crise en solidaire la réserve
civique qui donc ne vise à mobiliser des
français qui en ont le temps l'envié et
la motivation autour de missions vitales
pour le pays dans cette crise que nous
traversons est pour reprendre l'exemple
de la distribution alimentaire pour
aller permettra dé prendre distribution
d'ouvrir pour aller porter des repas
chez des personnes chez des personnes
vulnérables
la réserve civique a connu un succès
extrêmement important puisque 300 milles
plus de trois cent mille français ont
rejoint la réserve cilic se sont
inscrits pour aider pour se rendre utile
pendant ce confinement un élan tellement
importants qu'ils étaient supérieurs aux
missions disponibles pour être proposée
aux eaux sais c'est un peu plus de cent
mille français qui ont été mobilisés
dans une mission de la réserve physique
est donc très concrètement sur le
terrain ou à distance pour être utile
être utile aux autres
on m'avait posé à la présidence une
question sur l'article qui est prévu
dans le projet de loi sur cette question
de 2,2 de la réserve physique
l'objectif du gouvernement par cet
article notre objectif c'est d'élargir
le périmètre des personnes morales
éligibles à l'ensemble des personnes
morales qui exercent des missions de
service public notamment les société
anonyme à capitaux publics dans le temps
de l'urgence sanitaire je m'explique
nous avons eu au moment du versement des
minima sociaux et dans un contexte où la
poste fonctionner avec de grandes
difficultés
une inquiétude sur la capacité à gérer
les flux de bénéficiaires qui pourrait
se rendre dans les bureaux de poste et
nous avons envisagé un temps de
mobiliser des volontaires de la réserve
cilic pour
rappeler les consignes sanitaires de
distanciation pour garantir que les
choses se déroulent convenablement dans
l'accueil des bénéficiaires à la poste
ce qui n'est pas possible aujourd'hui en
raison du droit et ancrages législative
de la réserve civile
je le rappel de la loi de 2007
autre exemple sur la distribution de
masques dans les transports publics
il a été envisagé pour l'agglomération
parisienne et du métro de mobiliser des
volontaires pour participer à la
distribution de masques dans les
premiers jours du déconfinement pour les
français qui ne disposeraient pas de
masque grand public pour leur permettre
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible
légalement et donc l'objectif de cet
article est d'étendre périmètre des
personnes morales éligibles à la réserve
physique à l'ensemble de celles qui
exercent des missions de service public
le temps encore une fois de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire donc c'est
évidemment très encadrée à bord nous on
se dit qu'en car évidemment d'une route
de nouveaux pics de reconfirme ans ou
dans le cadre d'une autre crise qui
pourrait survenir le fait de se dire que
les paras la possibilité de manière
extrêmement encadrées sur des moments
précis de mobiliser des volontaires pour
venir en aide et venir appuyer et
structures qui exercent des missions de
service public même si elles n'ont pas
la nature jovetic d'établissement public
paraît nécessaire et en tout cas nous
souhaiterions pouvoir ou les prévoir
voilà profond à votre à votre question
le deuxième enjeu que j'évoquais et
celui de la jeunesse le défilement a eu
un impact en termes de précarité pour un
certain nombre des jeunes
je pense aux étudiants ultramarins qui
font leurs études dans l'hexagone et qui
n'ont pas q comme d'autres étudiants se
retourner vers une solidarité familiale
de proximité dans ce moment et donc pour
qui la crise à représenter des coûts
supplémentaires je pense à des étudiants
précaires qui avait un job étudiant un
stage qui ont assuré un revenu qui avait
par ailleurs accès aux restaurants
universitaires pour s'alimenter à
moindre coût qui ont perdu leur emploi
ou leur stage qui n'ont plus accès au
restaurant universitaire est donc à la
fois moindres revenus et des frais
supplémentaires
je pense enfin à des jeunes qui ne sont
pas étudiants les guides sont précaires
qui ont aussi été impactés par cette
crise et qui ont besoin d'une aide
financière pourra passer ce moment
difficile
ce qui à ce qui nous a conduit ce qui a
conduit le premier ministre a annoncé
devant le sénat la mise en place d'une
aide d'urgence exceptionnelle de 200
euros qui sera versée à huit cent mille
jeunes précaires suite à 25 ans qui sera
versée s'agissant des étudiants au début
du mois de juin et s'agissant des non
étudiants le 15 juin de manière
automatique pour eux puisque nous
fondant sur les jeunes étudiants et qui
sont bénéficiaires des apl de manière à
ce que ça puisse toucher le plus grand
nombre d'entre eux et ce qui me permet
d'ailleurs de rappeler que la plateforme
a ouvert sur le site et étudiants quand
vous pouvez faire pour ce qui est des
étudiants pour solliciter cette aide
cette aide exceptionnelle toujours sur
la question de la jeunesse jeudi rameaux
de la question de l'éducation populaire
ce qu'on appelle le le périscolaire qui
évidemment était là aussi
là aussi impactés et va en parler à la
fois s'agissant des structures sont
aussi des structures associatives qui
doivent être soutenus et annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures pour permettre
à ces structures de survivre à la crise
je pense par exemple aux structures
associatives qui est porte des accueils
de loisirs vous savez qu'elles sont
financées en fonction du nombre
d'enfants
quel accueil du nombre de jours où elle
accueille des enfants évidemment du fait
du confinement
ces structures ont été fermés pendant
plusieurs mois il y avait une très
grande inquiétude pour l s'agissant des
ressources puisque elles ont évidemment
des coûts fixes qu'elles ont dû
continuer à assumer est-ce que j'ai
avancé c'est que en 2020 l'état versera
à ses associations calme caf verseront à
ces associations le même montant le même
financement que celui qui avait été
versée en 2010 9 ans bien même elles ont
accueilli moins d'enfants il permet de
leur garantir
une stabilité des réalités dans leur
financement et permettre de passer ce
moment
de même que pour les associations qui
organisent des colonies vacances qui ont
organisé qui en avait organisé pour les
vacances de pâques qui organise des
classes de découverte des voyages
scolaires souvent les mêmes
aussi pour les vacances de pâques nous
avons pris des mesures pour leur
permettre là aussi être impactées par
cette crise
pour ce qui est des colonies de vacances
en leur donnant la possibilité de
réaliser un lavoir pour les familles
pour ce qui est des voyages scolaires
éducation nationale pris la perte entre
guillemets puisque elle a remboursé elle
même les familles qui avaient s'était
inquiété du coût d'un voyage scolaire
qui n'a pu se tenir là encore pour
protéger c'est une association
évidemment nous sommes très tourné là ce
qui pourra se passer cet été avec une
préoccupation sanitaire qui reste
importante puisque vous savez que les
annonces seront faites
globalement sur la question des vacances
et dur sur ce qui sera possible de faire
cet été
ed juin à l'occasion de la deuxième
étape du déguisement mais sans attendre
le des gens nous travaillons avec
jean-michel bancaire pour préparer ce
que sera et puis cet été après venant et
culturelle comme d'après et le président
m'a république
mais pour résumer sur notre capacité
avec les associations avec les
collectivités locales à permettre à tous
les enfants et notamment aux enfants qui
ont vécu le confinement le plus
difficile cette année de s'évader
d'aller en nature de rencontrer d'autres
enfants de s'épanouir et y compris de
rattraper un certain nombre
d'apprentissages qu'ils auront à manquer
du fait du confinement
chaque semaine l'ensemble des acteurs
sont réunis au ministère ou
d'associations d'éducation populaire des
acteurs évidemment de l'état dans des
collectivités locales pour travailler et
ce à quoi nous travaillons c'est déjà
une fusée à trois étages avec d'abord un
renforcement très important du
dispositif école ouverte qui vous le
savez existe depuis maintenant plusieurs
années qui permet d'accueillir les
enfants dans des établissements
scolaires le matin et d'organiser des
édité avec les accueils de loisirs de
l'après-midi développer très fortement
ce dispositif
cette année avec l'organisation de micro
séjour d'excursions dans une proximité
importante avec le lieu de résidence si
c'est une nécessité avec par exemple des
découvertes patrimoniales culturelles ou
l'organisation de micro séjour de type
scoutisme dans un environnement
champêtre par exemple et puis enfin
troisième étage la question des colonies
de vacances que nous devons soutenir et
développer facilement cet été évidemment
si une mobilité importante est possible
et si les regroupements d'enfants de
cette ampleur sont possibles sur ce
sujet là évidemment la réponse que qu'au
début juin mais nous travaillons d'ores
et déjà à dépister à des annonces que
nous pourrons faire pour ce secteur
enfin dernier grand secteur en chantier
celui de l'engagement cilic
cinquante-huit mille jeunes étaient en
mission de service civil comment nous
avons décidé confinement un certain
nombre d'entre eux autour de parme ils
ont pu poursuivre leur mission parce que
il exerçait dans des structures qui ont
poursuivi leur activité pendant le
confinement pense évidemment aux ehpad
je pense aux associations de solidarité
dead alimentaire et pour une majorité
des jeunes en service civique la mission
s'est interrompue je pense est par
exemple 12000 jeunes en service civique
qui sont rattachés à des établissements
scolaires ou à des associations qui ont
suspendu leurs activités
donc notre préoccupation à dos a été de
leur permettre de s'engager différemment
face à la crise
le propre des jeunes en service civique
c'est qu'ils sont engagés qu'ils ont
envie d'être utile à leur pays de servir
leur pays et donc leur avons
immédiatement proposé de rejoindre la
réserve civique pour s'inscrire dans les
missions que nous avions proposé pour
venir en aide aux français au moment de
cette crise cinquante mille jeunes du
service civique ont rejoint la raideur
cilic y compris des jeunes qui ont
poursuivi leur mission ont par ailleurs
rejoint la réserve faunique et des
encore davantage qui évidemment autre
ère très positif deuxième deuxième
dispositif important de l'engagement
civique évidemment impacté par la crise
du coronavirus c'est le service national
universel vous savez qu'il a commencé à
se déployer
l'an dernier avec une passe de
préfiguration de 2000 jeunes et qui
aborde cette année sa deuxième phase de
montée en puissance et qui a une
résonance très important puisque ce
service national vise à permettre à tous
les jeunes de à mesurer l'étendue des
possibles pour servir leur pays être
utile alors pays et aux autres et que en
cette année face à cette crise nous
avons plus que jamais besoin
d'engagement des français d'une manière
générale mais et jeunes en particulier
il faut évidemment que le sable
nationale puisse se tenir et remplir son
rôle
évidemment nous l'adaptons nous
l'adaptons puisque le séjour de cohésion
qui implique une mobilité des jeunes et
est soient regroupés dans des centres
cadres et militaires des associatifs et
des personnels de l'éducation nationale
devait avoir lieu à la fin du mois de
juin évidemment du fait des conditions
sanitaires ne peut soutenir longera la
mission d'intérêt général de les
soutenir
elle à l'automne prochain rappel les
jeunes d'aller dans une issue mentaires
général se rendre utile auprès d'une
association d'un corps en uniforme près
de chez eux et donc nous avons décidé
d'inverser les deux phases
donc les jeunes débuteront leur service
national universel avant l'été via leur
mission d'intérêt général pour venir en
aide à des associations et des
structures publiques particulièrement
mobilisés dans la crise duo coronavirus
et dans le cadre en l'occurrence du
confinement et le séjour de cohésion lui
se tiendra je l'espère à l'automne en
tout cas quand les conditions sanitaires
le permettront d une fiction comme
objectif
l'automne est d'accord de la toussaint
pour pu se tenir mais encore une fois
avec la grande interrogation de ce que
sera la situation à sanitaires et des
vides dans notre pays
ce à ce moment là je veux préciser ici
que les deux mille jeunes qui avaient
fait leur service national universel
l'an dernier se sont immédiatement
mobilisés face à cette crise - même
avant même que nous les sollicitions ils
nous ont sollicités pour savoir comment
se rendre utile ce qui montre bien que
cette expérience leur a permis de me
mesurer tout ce qu'il pouvait apporter
et de les aider à se mobiliser et à
révéler cette envie d'engagement et donc
nous leur avons adressé à tous à un kit
qui a été réalisé avec l'association
voisins solidaires pour leur permettre
de venir en aide à des personnes âgées
des personnes en situation de handicap
près de chez eux pour faire leurs
courses pour créer du lien humain social
et que cet engagement était très peur
voilà pour les chantiers évidemment
j'imagine qu'il y aura des questions et
je reviendrai dans les détails en tout
cas je crois que cette crise est
évidemment un moment très difficile pour
le pays et il y a des dimensions entre
guillemets lumineuse et réjouissante
dans cette crise
et l'élan de solidarité l'entr'aide du
quotidien entraîne des voisinages que
nous avons dû émerger la capacité de
résilience très forte des bénévoles et
des associations et de l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui sont engagés dans le
pays font partie des dimensions
extrêmement positive et réjouissante que
nous avons vu à l'occasion de cette
crise et je crois profondément que ce
que nous avons vu émerger dans cette
crise en matière d'entre elles
d'engagement et de solidarité
survivra au coronavirus que peut-être
que sur ces sujets que nous avons à
coeur de défendre je crois
collectivement par delà les clivages
politiques dans cette dans cette
commission
ces sujets pour moi aussi être rebooster
réinsuffler il ya cette crise et que cet
élan de solidarité pourra se poursuivre
assez longtemps dans notre pays en tout
cas c'est ce que j'espère merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur est à l'état je
vais passer tout de suite la parole à
notre rapporteur et animateur du groupe
de travail dont la plupart des membres
sont présentes
alors jacques bernard je te 7 la part
merci bonjour monsieur le ministre on
attendait c'est bon je peux m'exprimer
bien avant tout de dire de poser la
question je souhaite saluer la
mobilisation comme vous l'avez fait de
l'ensemble des bénévoles déjà du service
civique des associations qui sont
investis largement en faire face à cette
crise sanitaire et sociale que nous
avons traversée où il connut traversons
locale mais pas tout à fait terminée un
coin
en effet ils ont eu des mouvements et
des actions remarquables enzo tout à
fait collaborer contribuer au maintien
et au renforcement du lien social et
surtout ils ont soutenu ce ver ligne qui
étaient impliqués dans la lutte contre
le commis de 19 ou la commune je ne sais
pas en voir aux actions j'ai mis sur le
genre aussi je regrette que cette
mobilisation reste encore tout à fait
invisible aux yeux des pouvoirs publics
dans les principaux discours du
président enrico du premier ministre le
rôle des bénévoles n'a pas été saluée
même évoquée parfois c'est dommage
il me paraît pourtant essentiel que la
nation à une reconnaissance envers
l'engagement citoyen auquel on fait
souvent référence dans les discours ma
première question porte sur les mesures
de soutien à l'économie par pour les
associations lors de nos auditions 30
tête de réseau et qu'on s'organise ne
nous ont fait part d'un certain nombre
de difficultés si les associations
employeuses comme vous l'avez dit leur
ont vu leur situation réglée par l'axé
qui leur a été donné au fond de soi il a
été je vous en félicite puisque il
fallait effectivement obtenir cela je
souhaite tout de même vous alerter sur
la situation des associations qui ne
sont pas employés et qui pourtant ont
aussi des charges n'ont ni accès aux
fonds de prêts garantis par l'état denis
au fonds de solidarité et donc elles ont
des difficultés par exemple des charges
de nos pauvres des charges qui sont
nombreuses et qu'il faudra à la traiter
alors est ce qu'il y a des solutions qui
pourraient être apportées à six
associations qui elles seront
demandeuses nous ont pas attendus dans
les motifs y est ma deuxième série de
questions concerne le service civique
vous y est vous avez fait référence sans
reparler vous connaissez mon attachement
à ce dispositif qui a 10 ans maintenant
au moment où l'émission europan
progressivement les besoins des
structures augmente et de nombreux
jeunes vont arriver au terme de leur
contrat de service civique
plusieurs acteurs majeurs dont l' agence
du service civique et l'unicité
il plaide pour une prolongation de
quelques mois d'émission alors vous avez
évoqué celles qui ont été déjà prolongés
parce que c'était possible qu'ils ont
été
transformer mais on pourra envisager que
ces missions qui aujourd'hui et tourne
autour de 6 ou 7 mois en moyenne puisse
être prolongée notamment par la période
des temps dans la période d'été car il
ya beaucoup de besoins à satisfaire et
ça permettrait aux structures qui en ont
besoin d'avoir des gens qui sont déjà
formés qui sont déjà opérationnels et
qui sont déjà intégrées souvent dans des
structures qui ont besoin de pensez vous
que cette proposition ne peut être
adoptée je sais que vous n'avez pas des
quartiers cette possibilité puisque vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure et vous ne
savez pas écarté non plus lors d'une
audition à l'assemblée nationale avec ça
par ailleurs nombreux jeunes en service
civique qui ont été redéployés soit des
missions urgentes
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure ça ne
s'est pas fait sans certaines lourdeurs
administratives et incertitudes
juridiques parfois on mettait un peu
déjà en insécurité d'être en règle avec
un certain nombre de choses qui vous
avait prévu de faire auparavant pourrait
tourner prévoir d'intégrer dans tous les
prochains contrats de service civique la
possibilité de transférer ces jeunes
avec leur accord bien sûr sur une
mission d'urgence en cas de besoin et
avec une couverture sur par l'état en
cas de problème alors dans le prochain
projet de loi de finances ne d'urgence
pendant figure la demande d'habilitation
vous l'avez évoqué j'y reviendrai pas je
pense qu'effectivement il serait utile
de soutenir développer la réserve
civique et je pense que dans l'avenir
peut-être que on en reparlera
car elle a montré son utilité et son
efficacité même si comme vous l'avez dit
l'émission n'était pas toujours à la
hauteur de la volonté des chars de
participer à cette ses trésors civique
le ministre de l'éducation nationale que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure a beaucoup
parlé des colonies de vacances
apprenantes studieuse éducatives etc
que vouloir ça le dérange beaucoup
notamment les organismes qui organisent
qui ont l'habitude de gérer ses
collègues vacances on nous sommes à deux
mois seulement des vacances scolaires il
devient urgent de définir le rôle des
gens dans ces colonies
s'agit-il d'un soutien scolaire ou
plutôt acquisitions que de connaissances
vous savez à qui
connaissance c'est fait par des
spécialistes des professeurs des écoles
quel est le rôle à des questions
nationales dans ses colonies
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
ce quoi parce que on ne peut pas
demander dès qu'ils sont déjà des
colonies des lieux éducatifs puisque
d'accueillir vacances on apprend bonne
chose d'être d'un seul coup des lieux où
on fait du soutien scolaire ou des
apprentissages scolaires avec des gens
qui ne sont pas des professionnels de
l'éducation
enfin enfin gevo créé le service
national universel
on l'avait rappelé vous voulez maintenir
sa généralisation son ensemble des
départements pour trente mille jeunes de
cette année moi je pense qu'il serait
plus judicieux de remettre cette
généralisation à 2021 mais je ne suis
pas le seul et concentrant au service
civique et que les budgétaire qui était
affecté les des 30 millions d'euros
peut-être plus même puisque ont passé de
20 millions de vingt mille jeunes les
jeunes mais on a peut-être aussi une
piste en mettant des moyens pour
renforcer la réserve civique avec des
jeunes plus nombreux en service civique
ne sont pas des solutions dans ces temps
incertains
voilà j'espère n'avoir pas été trop je
remercie merci monsieur rapport comme si
le ministre pour les premières réponses
il ya beaucoup d'orateurs inscrits il
est évident que non pas du tout non
c'est pas ça
maintenant il derrière alors première
question vous avez posées sur des
associations ils ne sont pas employeuse
et qui donc pas bénéficier du chômage
partiel comment soutenue alors que vous
évoquez que des associations peuvent ne
pas être employeuse et avoir des charges
d'abord je rappelle les reports de
charges pour toutes les associations
premièrement ensuite pour moi cette
association mais soutenons d'abord en
garantissant le maintien des subventions
en bien même elles ne peuvent pas
réaliser leurs activités ce qui est la
ressource sur laquelle elle avait prévu
2,2 de compte et en leur permettant
l'accès aux prêts garantis par l'état
qui ne dépend pas du tout du fait
d'avoir un
un salarié ou pas mais dit avoir une
activité économique
il ya le nom de l'association qui n'ont
pas de salarié mais qui ont une activité
économique est assez peu étendu mais ça
existe
il ya plusieurs exemples donc évidemment
il faut il faut les avoir en tête le psg
répond
et puis enfin un autre à enjeu pour moi
important c'est le sève d'hévéa
ça me des dégâts qui a remplacé la
réserve parlementaire
j'ai eu beaucoup d'interrogations et
d'inquiétudes au départ sur le maintien
du calendrier puisque chris hughes
coronavirus est arrivé exactement au
moment où des subventions avaient été
plus ou moins acte est décidé plus ou
moins affichée par les commissions mais
pas encore ap est versée est évidemment
j'ai demandé aux services que les
commissions à des as se tiennent dans le
calendrier prévu voire même allé plus
vite que ce qui était prévu quand les
subventions tu cèdes versé avant l'été
aux associations sur le service civique
vous m'avez interrogé sur la question du
prolongement des démissions moi là
dessus je pense qu'il faut être prêt il
faut se poser la question du besoin de
la nécessité pour les structures qui
accueillent déjà d'un service il dire
par principe il faut prolonger tous les
contrats de service civique du nombre de
mois qu'a duré le confinement pour moi
ça n'a pas grand sens parce que il ya
des structures qui accueillent des
jeunes en service civique qui n'ont pas
d'activité l'été exemple le plus
frappant pense l'éducation nationale où
par définition et douze mille jeunes qui
sont accueillis en service civique qu'il
était au début du confinement à les
garder en juillet-août même s'il peut y
avoir sur telle ou telle mission
notamment à un dispositif école ouverte
besoin de jeunes mais pas lieu d'avoir
une mesure générale
ensuite je veux dire que l'émission ne
se sont pas interrompues parce que c'est
important de le préciser aussi mais les
jeunes ont continué à recevoir leurs
indemnités de service civique
même s'ils étaient confinés chez eux
s'ils n'avaient plus leur art leur
activité il a été donnée aux jeunes la
possibilité de demander à ne pas
percevoir leurs indemnités en
finement pour justement pouvoir
poursuivre leur mission derrière et que
la réalité continue à exercer qui
continuent leurs activités auprès de la
sauce de l'association de la structure
et enfin la troisième préoccupation est
que telle décision ne se ne conduisent
pas à retarder ou annuler l'arrêt des
deux jeunes en service civique est
prévue dans les mois à venir dans des
structures
je n'ai pas du tout entendu ça dans vos
propos je crois pas du tout que soit
votre attention mais je le dis parce que
je notamment reçu un courrier avec
lettre ouverte des cuts et les
républicains à l'assemblée nationale
demandant la prolongation des missions
de service civique dans des structures
et donc d en précisant que cela
reviendrait par ailleurs annulé
l'arrivée des jeunes qui étaient prévus
dans ces structures
je pense qu'il ya des jeunes qui avaient
prévu de commencer un service civique en
ce moment dans les mois qui viennent se
sont organisés en fonction et qu'on va
évidemment pas leur retirer leur mission
de service y est donc
il est décidé pour un certain nombre de
structures de prolonger l'émission en
plus des jeunes qui doivent arriver cet
été il ya un impact budgétaire dont le
rapporteur est donc c'est un enjeu qui
est en train d'être regardés dans le
cadre des arbitrages budgétaires qui
sont en cours et nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler leur revient sur la
question de l'insécurité juridique sur
le service civique
justement ce que nous avons voulu faire
dès le départ c'est de prendre aucun
risque et ne faire prendre aucun risque
aux structures
donc il ya eu au départ pendant deux
semaines effectivement un moment nous
avons tous suspendus et où les jeunes en
service civique ont suspendu un temps
leur mission parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
prendre faire prendre de risques
juridiques aux structures qui
accueillent des jeunes équipes a déclaré
et par définition la situation est
parfaitement inédite et donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya des dimensions qui n'avait
jamais été anticipé par l' agence du
service civique est donc la solution qui
a été trouvée de faire signer aux jeunes
et aux structures un avenant au contrat
de service civique est une bonne
solution qui a permis de débloquer les
choses très vite et donc posé la
question de savoir s'il fallait que ce
soit cette société soit intégrée dès le
départ dans le contrat du jeune pourquoi
parce qu'il faut qu'on regarde en tout
cas parce que à la lumière de cette
expérience il faut qu'on prenne les
dispositions qui permettent évidemment
d'avoir cette agilité
si une crise survient à nouveau et
autres cas maintenant voit assez bien le
processus qu'il faut mettre en place
avec l'avenant
ça puisse aller assez vite totalement
d'accord pour garder sur la nature sur
l'évolution du programme sur la question
des colonies de vacances
je suis parfaitement il totalement
lucide et conscient de toutes les
questions que se posaient les acteurs
les opérateurs dit ou écrit le disent
quand je les rencontre quand une fois
une réunion toutes les semaines ou au
ministère avec hull mais les équipes et
il ya des questions qui se posent
notamment sur l'âge met de côté le fait
de savoir s'il pourrait y avoir une
mobilité large à cet été qui sera
tranché le de jambes et les questions
qu'ils se posent sur le protocole
sanitaire et des questions qui se posent
sur ce que signifie concrètement l'idée
de vacances apprenantes et culturel pour
pour ses forces et acteurs là dessus moi
je peux dire que nous avons bien avancé
dans le travail avec les principaux
acteurs
c'est toujours compliqué de les citer
parce qu'on en oublie toujours mais
voilà il ya des échanges très nourris
qui ont des partages de cahier des
charges avec us tv avec léo lagrange
avec la ligue de l'enseignement
avec les haies avec la jeunesse au plein
air jeux je pourrais en citer beaucoup
mais en gros objectif c'est d'avoir un
forme de cahier des charges a forcément
de labellisation mais le cahier des
charges qui explique très concrètement
ce que recouvrent ces vacances
apprenantes et culturel au fond l'idée
exprimée président de la république
c'est de dire que évidemment une colonie
de vacances en expérience avec
l'éducation populaire
c'est toujours un moment d'apprentissage
pour les jeunes on apprend toujours en
colonie de vacances on apprend toujours
dans un accueil de loisirs
on apprend toujours au contact d'une
association d'un mouvement d'éducation
populaire cette année du fait du
confinement beaucoup d'enfants ont le
ced perdu un temps important s'agissant
de leur apprentissage formelle et la
question qui est posée si comment est-ce
que ces peptides
nous permettons à la fois aux enfants de
vivre cette éducation non formelle et
cet apprentissage qui est porté par les
associations et en même temps si plus
permettre d'avoir en forme de tutorat de
rattrapage plus formel à cette occasion
ça peut passer par des interventions à
par des enseignants volontaires
ça peut passer par l'utilisation par les
associations de ressources qui sont
produites par l'éducation nationale
ça peut passer par des modules nouveau
de lui dit qu'ils sont portés par des
associations et qui permettent
d'atteindre des objectifs sont
poursuivis par l'éducation nationale
c'est tout ce travail là qui est en
train d'être refaite et l'objectif c'est
d'avoir un cahier des charges
sony de partager avec les acteurs et
c'est vraiment ce à quoi nous sommes en
train de travailler
enfin sur le service national universel
moi je dis à mon importance de jeu deux
profils pas de généralités sur cette
année puisque généralisation c'est
qu'hormis cent mille jeunes seront
concernés on est là sur la deuxième
étape de monter en puissance
je suis pas totalement certain que les
arguments de redéploiements budgétaires
soient parfaitement opérant parce que
betty ou même d'ailleurs en le disant
on parle d'un budget pour le s est venue
cette année qui est prévue à 30 millions
d'euros
quand on le met à côté du budget du
service civique qui est de plus de 500
millions d'euros on voit que c'est pas
du tout les mêmes échelles et que ça
n'est pas ça qui ferait la différence en
matière de service civique et si je
rentre à votre proposition de prolonger
le contrat de service civique de tous
les jeunes
la durée du confinement je crois que
l'application budgétaire et détours 250
millions d'euros donc donc nous le
budget prévu pour le fc mulhouse ne
permettrait pas d'arriver à ces
changements là comme ça de slick
d'ailleurs je défends les deux j'ai
toujours fait je continue à le faire et
donc des ressources budgétaires
supplémentaires en propre pour le
service
merci
sur le se mettent à l'état alors je vais
donner la parole pour commencer à
dominique guérilla qui était rapporteur
dans le cadre de la mission dédiée aux
violences sexuelles
la jeunesse et qu'il est peut être pour
vous éclairer sur un autre problématique
voilà et ensuite l'ensemble des
collègues bien entendu vont s'exprimer à
moulis peroni juste après façon à ce que
les collègues il se prépare et ce
bonhomme de neige
merci merci beaucoup madame la
présidente monsieur ministre merci
beaucoup pour cette présentation
alors je reviendrai juste un petit peu
sur le service de cilic pour continuer
ce que notre reporter a dit parce qu'il
est vrai que dans les auditions que nous
avons pu avoir il a été demandé à ce que
le service de suivi que soit un peu plus
un peu plus long dire qu'il était
initialement de 9 mois aujourd'hui la
durée moyenne est plutôt de six mois et
ils se disent que au moins huit mois
serait quand même plutôt nécessaire pour
pouvoir faire un vrai travail de fond
avec un certain nombre de jeunes qui se
recherchent donc effectivement c'est aux
alentours de 50 minutes 150 millions
d'euros à peu près de pouvoir rallonger
mais je pense que comme vous l'avez dit
service civique rend vraiment un vrai
service et ça n'est pas pour rien que
sur les soixante mille jeunes 58 se sont
effectivement engagés dans la réserve
civique
par ailleurs toujours sur le service de
cilic je crois qu'on a découvert aussi
qu'on pouvait bien travailler via des
réunions zoom est donc là je voulais
parler de la ruralité où on a souvent du
mal à avoir des service civique un peu
pour des raisons de deux logements mais
aussi beaucoup pour des raisons
d'encadrement parce que souvent
l'encadrement se trouve dans la ville
centre est donc un peu éloigné de des
possibilités de service civique qui
serait à la campagne or là on voit que
l'encadrement pourrait se faire malgré
tout à distance et finalement s'il ya
une leçon à retenir de cette crise
c'est probablement ça et que finalement
c'est beaucoup mieux tous servir de
plein d'outils et que
avec des liaisons parfois par
extraordinaire on arrive quand même à
communiquer ma deuxième question et sur
les colonies de vacances je reviendrai
pas sur les structures mais plutôt sur
les cibles j'ai cru comprendre de ce que
vous avez dit que votre cible première
était probablement les enfants qui
avaient subi un confinement vraiment
confiné donc sans forcément pouvoir
sortir sans forcément pouvoir avoir un
véritable accès à la nation apprenantes
et aux services qu'ils pouvaient être
rendus par l'éducation nationale qui
fait un gros travail là dessus
comment est ce que vous pensez pouvoir
toucher ce public cible parce que on se
rend compte notamment nous quand on fait
des questionnements dans mon secteur
pour le retour à l'école qui est sur la
base du volontariat un certain nombre de
parents ne répondent même pas savoir
s'ils vont envoyer ou pas leurs enfants
à l'école c'est à dire que y'a quand
même un décrochement je pense que ces
familles sont effectivement prioritaire
pour les fameuses colonie de vacances
mais comment est-ce qu'on peut les
toucher et est vraiment les intéressés
qui payent le surtout parce qu'il y aura
malgré tout un surcoût parce que moins
d'enfants et plus de contraintes et
probablement aussi des activités un peu
différente
donc voilà bah en fait et comment
comment on arrive à aller toucher
merci et je donne la parole maintenant
un madame de boulay espejo nier merci
beaucoup à la présidente monsieur
ministre à un hors-jeu de la sortie de
crise est de réussir à conserver le
capital de l'engagement qui a été
l'engagement d'un grand nombre d'actifs
pendant le confinement bruit vous en
avez largement parlé je souscris est ce
que vous avez dit totalement donc il me
vient une petite question très rapide
tout de suite vous avez évoqué la
réserve civique avec plus de trois cent
mille français qui sont inscrits sur la
plateforme sommes prévues à cet effet
hors cent mille français seulement n'ont
pu que ce mot vieillesse que ça na pas
créer trop de frustration et on fait les
autres qui ont ce qui est absolument se
mobiliser dans le cadre cette crise
dans le cas de cette crise sanitaire
j'ai deux autres questions relativement
rapide à paris dont je suis élu en
faisant cas du caractère
particulièrement difficile du
confinement en milieu urbain de manière
générale et les tur gens que les jeunes
puissent retrouver une forme de
socialisation conforme au respect des
règles sanitaires à travers les
initiatives associatives
monsieur le ministre en conséquence afin
d'atteindre cet objectif est d'engager
la reprise de la vie associative
par delà les limites des catégories de
soutien social et l'aide alimentaire
pouvez vous nous indiquer les activités
que les associations notamment sportives
sont en mesure de mettre en oeuvre dans
le respect des règles sanitaires
actuellement en vigueur
les activités aujourd'hui autorisés dans
le cadre périscolaire pourrait-elle
rapidement être autorisé dans les mêmes
conditions de maintien des gestes
barrières dans le cadre associatif
par ailleurs qui n'a rien à voir j'ai
été interpellé au sujet de la situation
des logopèdes en stage d'équivalence
pour l'exercice de la profession
d'orthophoniste en france conformément
au décret du 30 août 2013 la
reconnaissance du diplôme de ces
étudiants est conditionnée par la
réalisation d'un stage dont la durée est
établie par les directions régionales de
la jeunesse et des sports à ce jour 800
à 1000 heures de pratique sont en
moyenne exigée afin de pouvoir exercer
la profession d'orthophoniste en france
malheureusement en la crise actuelle
nombre de nouveaux raids ont vu leur
stage repoussait une échéance ultérieure
voire annuler cette situation les place
dans une grande précarité puisque dans
l'antre 2 ils ne peuvent être reconnus
ni comme étudiant ni comme stagiaire ni
comme salarié il nous est difficile par
conséquent d'aucune aide sociale ni
d'aucun des mécanismes de soutien
économique mis en place dans le cadre de
la lutte contre la propagation du coc
u19 compte tenu des besoins de
rééducation grandissant des patients
sortants de réanimation leur expertise
paraît pourtant plus que jamais
nécessaires au système de santé français
monsieur ministre type donc envisager
que les moyens compensatoires prévues
pour les étudiants français à l'école
d'orthophonie à savoir la réducation à
la suppression du nombre d'heures de
stage prévu leur soit étendu et
puisqu'il a été largement pour fini
question des colonies de vacances moi je
voudrais quand même pour parler des
organisations scouts de france vous
savez que c'est 160 mille adhérents
sans compter les familles et qu' il se
pose la question pour les scouts de la
tenue de leur camp d'été alors ce sont
les associations soutenues ne dépendent
pas de l'état et ne reçoivent très peu
de subventions mais pour autant il est
urgent qu'elles ne perdent pas d'argent
et d'adhérents avec des familles qui
pourraient se tourner vers d'autres
organisations pour les injecter que le
scoutisme et je pense notamment à des
difficultés qu'elle rencontre est lié au
fait qu'elle dépende du règlement de
l'accueil des mineurs est liée pour les
camps d'été
elles ne pourront pas bénéficier des
cinq d'accueil en plein air quant à
bénéficier les autres années voilà
j'espère je n'ai pas été trop longue et
joe merci madame boulet ce dernier
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse
prendre des notes
au fur et à mesure je vous invite à
remettre notre caméra parce que vous
êtes de généreusement effacé l'écran
mais je pense que l'ensemble des
collègues tiennent quand même à vous
voir tout au long cette audition voilà
donc je vais donner maintenant la parole
à monsieur karam on va se transporter de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique monsieur
karam aidé avec will et en guyane
il s'adapte au décalage horaire ou le
remercie en toiture en tôle ce que vous
me voyez donc voilà
peut-être voir mais ta caméra non mais
attendez je vais mettre la caméra et là
ça vous convient
je ne dois pas moi mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave l'essentiel c'est que
vous puissiez m'attendre bonjour
monsieur le ministre gabriel donc je
vais prendre la parole pas encore
quelques minutes pour vous dire que la
prise en compte de l'impact du
confinement sur les apprentissages pose
un vrai défi pour les vacances scolaires
et j'ai noté donc avec intérêt la
proposition de dugny jean michel blanc
père s'agissant des colonies apprenantes
et d'ailleurs ça a été soulignée par mon
collègue rapporteur jean jacques bernard
banny manier et je partage
il faut le dire ces inquiétudes ce que
nous le savons les conséquences
économiques et sociales de cette crise
touche encore plus dur plus durement
lève camille et les plus modestes
il est donc important de permettre aux
enfants les plus fragiles de bénéficier
d'un enseignement au travers des formes
hybrides de séjour alors vous connaissez
bien mon territoire puisque vous êtes
vous y êtes donné plusieurs fois j'ai
régulièrement fait part du monde mes
angoisses
quant à la continuité pédagogique des
enfants sur des sites isolés
alors vous savez que n'arrive jamais le
numérique internet et tout ce qui s'en
suit le télé-enseignement certaine
fracture numérique pour laisser le champ
libre au décrochage scolaire alors j'ai
deux questions très content sur le
ministre pouvait nous nous assurer qu'il
existera bien dans chaque département de
france une offre de séjour à prenant les
deuxième question dans le prolongement
pouvez vous me dire si la plateforme
je veux aider point fr et la réserve
civiques ont vocation à soutenir
localement la mise en place de ces
séjours et l'ouverture des écoles voilà
j'en ai terminé merci et monsieur
capables de nous oublier mon somme des
coûts sont en train de s'exprimer
voilà parce que je pense que c'est bon
vous m'entendez fait bien être la caméra
aussi pierre voilà oui voilà
bonjour merci madame la présidente
bonjour monsieur le ministre bon je veux
aussi vous parler des colonies de
vacances vous voyez c'est un un
processus de génération nous sommes tous
passés et peut-être que finalement on a
gagné la nôtre notre engagement
politique et de notre engagement pour
pour la collectivité parce que les
colonies de vacances c'était aussi ça
l'apprentissage d'une vie en commun je
pense que c'est je pense que c'est
fondamental pour ministre blanc caire et
vous même à plusieurs reprises avait
fait allusion à propos des colonies
vacances au programme du conseil
national de la résistance et vous
toucher au coeur parce que c'est ça
l'art est une une référence est telle
que le conseil national de la résistance
avait défini les les colonies de
vacances en 1945 après le plan langevin
wallon il y avait trois objectifs
majeurs d'abord une oeuvre sociale il
faut le rappeler c'est important ensuite
le moyen de développement d'une
éducation populaire
c'était tout à fait essentiel est la
troisième ambition qui était la plus
forte c'est est de constituer un
véritable service public rattaché au
ministère de l'éducation nationale
j'aimerais que ça toi votre votre
ambition présentement alors y est bien
évidemment un problème de moyens comment
restructurer ce qui a été trop
déstructuré par par le passé
comment retrouver des potentialités qui
aujourd'hui ont disparu notamment dans
les collectivités mais n'est pas
seulement
et d'autre part quel est votre votre
projet politique dans le sens noble du
terme pour donner un contenu à ce axe
qui pourrait être être enseignée partage
et danser dans ces colonies de vacances
je crois qu'on a besoin d'un cadrage
national et on a besoin que vous nous
disiez exactement à quoi
vous ministère l'éducation nationale
vous souhaitiez leur donner comme comme
mission première est comme mission de
service public
voilà je remercie merci monsieur
ouzoulias monsieur ça va eh bien
bonjour monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente je vais
peut-être simuler mon intervention sur
trois questions autres et compterait sur
les associations vous n'avez parlé tout
à l'heure
il ya une réflexion d démener et la
ministre des sports votre collègue nous
a aussi indiqué que le gouvernement
travaill ait actuellement sur un plan
ambitieux de relance pour les
associations et que vous avez bientôt
nous de présenter qu'un défilé pouvez
vous nous préciser ce que vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure vous nous préciser
quelles sont les grandes lignes de cette
affection en direction des associations
sur l'économie ce bel collègues l'ont
déjà beaucoup évoqué simplement une
question il ya un plan tourisme de plus
2 1 milliards d'euros qui doit être
présenté demain puisque les colonies de
vacances pourront en bénéficier
c'est une question parce que ça fait
partie aussi de l'économie touristique
au niveau des colonies sur les
territoires et dans quel cadre et enfin
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure à juste
raison la députée qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer des associations avec des
pertes de recettes sur des
manifestations ou d'équipé est prévu
pour cette période de confinement et
donc qui voient leurs recettes diminuer
et malheureusement leurs dépenses elles
ne baissent pas bien sûr il ya moyen de
2 pour les associations de bénéficier de
recettes nouvelles ces de mécénat ou ses
alliés
on avait travaillé ensemble sur des
propositions à quelle mesure êtes-vous
prêt encourager le mécénat au moins de
façon temporaire pendant cette période
afin d'aider et soutenir les structures
qui sont menacés par mds de recettes
ça peut être une solution d'encourager
les entreprises et les priver de venir
soutenir le milieu associatif avec un
médecin
à qui pourrait être revu à la hausse par
rapport aux règles actuelles
merci monsieur le ministre voilà merci
donc je donne la parole ensuite à madame
jour vous perdez ce savoir monsieur le
ministre vous prenez des notes n'est pas
trop long cabella merci oui vous
m'entendez à bien par contre je sais pas
ce que je fais à l'image tout à fait si
oui merci merci madame madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je n'ai
pas vraiment une question parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dites mais je
voudrais rebondir sur l'intervention de
jacques bernard magner sur les crédits
du service civique
nous nous accordons tous à dire que
depuis le début de la crise de
sanitaires engagement des jeunes
accomplissant un service civique a été
remarquable à plus d'un titre notamment
auprès de nos aînés avant début du
confinement plusieurs structures
associatives ont souhaité attirer votre
attention sur les difficultés qu'elle
rencontre à répondre à la demande
croissante de services civiques tout en
composant avec un niveau de ressources
dont l'évolution est beaucoup plus
modeste certaines redoutent également
que lors des prochains exercices
budgétaires les crédits du service
civique connaissent une dynamique
inverse de ceux octroyés au service
national universel qui vous tient
également à coeur comme vous l'avez dit
j'espère donc que le gouvernement
restera attentif aux moyens alloués au
service civique afin de ne pas
compromettre la qualité des missions
proposées et des formations dispensées
dans le cadre de ce dispositif
merci madame joue madame mélo
indépendante
voilà je suis là je suis bien je me suis
bien d'un cran
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez déjà apporté ou
d'éléments concernant la jeunesse
mais je voudrais encore approfondir ce
sujet vous poser une question sur les
modalités d'accueil des enfants centre
de loisirs est en colonie de vacances de
nombreux centres de loisirs et ouvre
progressivement dans le respect du
protocole national prévoyant notamment
le mythe de la taille des groupes
d'enfants et de fortes contraintes en
matière de transport et de restauration
les places restent encore très limité ce
qui peut du temps poser les problèmes
famille d'autre part le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a annoncé la mise
en place de vacances à prenante mais les
organisateurs de colonies de vacances
mais que la gale ont déjà parlé reste
dans l'expectative dans la tente les
prochaines décisions gouvernementales
vous avez dit que c'est travailler on
l'a un cahier des charges est en train
d'être élaborée mais je voulais vous
pointer le manque de clarté même si je
suis consciente que c'est un peu
difficile dans certaines communes on les
sénateurs sont des représentants des
collectivités locales dans certaines
communes ces centres ont bien relevé de
cette semaine dans d'autres on me dit
que l'autorisation des n'a pas été
donnée je ne sais pas si le protocole a
été mis en place mais les collectivités
ne savent ne semble pas bien informés
sur le sujet des centres de loisirs et
pour les colonies de vacances bon bien
sûr il ya encore un bon mois avant
d'arriver aux vacances même si semaine
il faudrait quand même pouvoir accélérer
un peu le processus parce que même s'il
s'agit de mini
jours sur place vous avez parlé de
séjour avec visite du patrimoine
voilà ce type de rôle du type scoutisme
dans des régions où il ya matière c'est
le cas de la seine et marne où il ya des
forêts on peut très bien emmené les
enfants en forêt bon mais je voudrais
savoir si le contact a été pris avec les
collectivités parce que habituellement
s'il faut ouvrir les écoles par exemple
faudrait s'organiser
finalement les écoles sont fermées bon
il ya des des sujets pratiques comme le
ménage à faire il faut du personnel
enfin bon il ya des détails à régler
donc voilà les parents ça veut pas de
votre côté s'ils pourront si rose
enfants pourront être admis en en centre
de loisirs ou en colonie de vacances et
de notre côté les collectivités locales
qui ont été déjà bien occupé par
l'organisation de la reprise les
établissements scolaires ne savent pas
non plus qu'on peut attendre des prépas
voilà les prendre au dépourvu
what joie merci beaucoup merci madame et
nos bonnes âmes robert bien bonjour
monsieur le ministre
bonjour madame la présidente et à tous
mes collègues
j'aurai trois petites questions la
première concerne la question des jeunes
et singulièrement de leur précarité de
leur vulnérabilité vous en avez parlé on
a salué le vraiment cette première étape
de la part du premier ministre la
semaine dernière de verser 200 euros à
ses huit cent mille jeunes
mais vous savez comme moi et pour avoir
audition entre autres avec un certain
nombre de mes collègues de la directrice
du cnous mais d'autres que
malheureusement on observe une vraiment
grande précarité un développement de la
grande précarité des
est jeune et pas seulement des étudiants
bien sûr je parlais du cnous mais pas
seulement des étudiants vous le savez
est donc une idée circule actuellement
je voudrais avoir votre point de vue qui
serait ce rsa ou un autre dispositif
jeunes bien sûr moins de 25 ans comme
entre 18 et 25 ans je voudrais avoir
votre votre point de vue sur sur 7 sur
ce dispositif ont en tout cas voilà
c'est cette idée qui circule
actuellement
- deuxième idée concerne les idées
question concerne les associations mais
tout est un peu lié dans la fragilité
qui est actuellement celle de beaucoup
d'associations et on le voit dans nos
territoires
est ce que l'idée des emplois aidés vous
est revenue comme ça dans cette période
d'après d'après confinement pour à la
fois parce qu'on sait que beaucoup de
jeunes ne vont pas avoir vont avoir
vraiment des difficultés à retrouver à
retrouver un emploi d'autres la question
de l'insertion est assez forte
leur fragilité liée à d'ailleurs à
l'absence de en tout cas de stages et
d'emplois
à côté de leurs études pour certains est
un vrai sujet aussi la question des
emplois aidés pour et de nouveaux
peut-être une nouveau une question
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
et puis je terminerai par mais alors
beaucoup mes collègues on parlait des
fameuses colonies moi j'ai entendu le
président de la république et le
ministre la culture dans sa conférence
de presse d'hier qu'il fallait que les
artistes soient aux côtés des jeunes
qu'il fallait absolument qu avec le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
même pendant les vacances y ait des
ateliers à leur éducation artistique et
culturelle je ne sais pas que l'état
serait dans l'accompagnement de deux de
ses projets et que ça pouvait d'ailleurs
être ce qui est actuellement pas
possible aujourd'hui je dirais dans la
question l'assurance chômage et
notamment des intermittents en plus de 2
des annonces du président de la
république un moyen de pouvoir garantir
si quelques heures est-ce que là aussi
dans votre réflexion les artistes et le
milieu culturel et est au coeur de cette
réflexion pour l'été prochain parce
qu'on aimerait bien savoir nous dans les
villes pour savoir un peu comment cybard
tirs cette saison d'été voilà donc trois
questions assez précises qui appelle des
réponses mais je n'en doute pas de votre
part aussi précise merci monsieur
ministre merci madame robert monsieur
lafon a demandé la parole également
monsieur lafon montante il
puis je vous entends la présidente
bonjour monsieur le ministre
moi je voudrais aborder deux thèmes
parmi les trois que vous avez abordé en
univers d'abord sur la question des
associations on l'a bien compris les les
les actions que vous avez mis en oeuvre
pour les soutenir
vous avez dit évidemment on peut pas
tout et les soutenir et cris avait des
critères qui avaient été mises en place
notamment le fait de soutenir celles qui
ont une activité économique et je
voulais attirer votre attention sur une
catégorie d'associations qui ont une
activité économique par essence et qui
pour autant des difficultés par rapport
aux notamment prêts garantis par l'état
mais aussi au fonds de solidarité
ce sont les associations de l'économie
sociale et solidaire es qui pour des
raisons qui sont liées à leur montage et
notamment leur montage financier soit
ont des difficultés à obtenir des
financements alors même que on le sait
peuvent ils tiennent un rôle et ils
peuvent tenir un rôle important dans
l'est dans les semaines et les poils
mais savoir si vous aviez une nation
s'il envisageait une action spécifique
concernant des associations de l'es16
sur le fonds de développement de la vie
associative
vous avez souligné et vous avez bien
fait que le calendrier va être accéléré
pour faire en sorte que l'argent soit
déboursée le plus rapidement possible
est-ce qu'il est aussi envisager une
modification des critères notamment pour
introduire des critères que vous avez
d'ailleurs énonce très haut débit trop
de propos sur les conséquences de la
crise en termes de demande de recettes
des difficultés de trésorerie etc
est ce que ça peut être des éléments
pris en compte dans le les attributions
du duel tenir sept tonnes cette année
sur la jeunesse alors j'allais poser
aussi la question sur le rsa mais si
robert l'a fait avant moi donc je tenais
je m'élève entendre votre point de vue
là dessus de même que sur le
renforcement puisque c'est demandé par
un certain nombre d'associations de
jeunesse
mieux le renforcement du parcours
contractualiser d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi on sait qu'il ya une
problématique n'est plus forte encore
que dans l'est - passé de l'accès à
l'emploi pour les jeunes
est ce que pour vous c'est un outil qui
mérite d'être renforcée dans les
semaines à venir
et puis dernière petite remarque elle
peut paraître eux j'allais dire d'une
moindre ampleur mais tout est important
actuellement un certain nombre de jeunes
n'ont pas pu faire leur stage erasmus
pour les raisons que l'on connaît
il a la possibilité de quitter le pays
or dans le règlement des rasmussen
règles assez strictes je crois qui dit
qu' on ne peut pas dans un cycle
universitaire faire deux fois une
mobilité race plus est ce que ce serait
aussi de modifier exceptionnellement
évidemment le règlement d'erasmus pour
permettre aux jeunes qui n'ont pas pu
partir du fait des études de la crise
due qu'aux villes puissent le faire
l'année prochaine
si monsieur la foule n'a pas eu la
chance de voir l'écran paco pour la
question sur pas qu i bonjour monsieur
d'état bonjour madame la présidente vous
m'entendez oui mais on ne va pas oui
parce que je suis sur un portable on m'a
dit que sur les portables ça passait pas
mais bon j'ai je vois mon ami la fonte
l'écouté serais bref les sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur notamment été évoquée
par laurent lafon et par jacques bernard
magner les deux petites questions quand
même cependant relative d'abord au petit
entre l'image associations et puis à la
problématique des jeunes qui viennent
d'achever leur cursus de formation alors
monsieur le ministre a évoqué le f des
verts en disant que l'année 2000 va sera
une année pleine entre guillemets ceci
étant si les grosses associations sont
bien soutenus notamment parce qu'elles
n'ont pu bénéficier du chômage partiel
pour les petites associations
cette année malheureusement on sera
catastrophique une petite association
qui tire son financement avant tout par
exemple de la brocante du village qui
pourra pas avoir lieu cette année
eh ben elle aura une petite subvention
de sa commune peut-être du département
si elle a de la chance du sève d'hévéa
mais ça va être très compliqué l'idéal
mais bon on peut toujours rêver ce
serait que le fdp a soit revalorisé
puisque vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que c'était un transfert de la
nasa parlementaire certes mais a minima
entre guillemets pourcentage est un
petit peu réduite bon néanmoins et
j'arrive sur la deuxième question on
risque d'avoir une promotion non pas une
génération une promotion d'étudiants
sacrifier ce qui a au printemps était en
recherche de stage ou qu'ils allaient
commencer des stages parfois au sein de
d'entreprise qui n'auront pas les moyens
qu'ils n'auront pas les moyens
malheureusement de prendre ces jeunes
stagiaires et donc pour qu'il n'y ait
pas cette génération plutôt cette
promotion sacrifiés
il serait bon que dans le cadre du plan
de relance ou du prochain plfr qui va
arriver y ait un aspect particulier pour
cette jeunesse alors c'est facile à dire
mais notre gouvernement a fait de gros
efforts avec des milliards d'euros des
dizaines de milliards d'euros
peut-être que vis-à-vis de la vie
associative vis-à-vis de la jeunesse
il faut faire à mon avis un effort qui
sera beaucoup moins coûteux mais qui
doit être conséquent voilà alors nos
petites associations elles ont un rôle
social
elles ont peut-être pas un rôle
économique maison un rôle social que
nous connaissons tous
elles ont besoin de ce soutien et je
sais que vous saurez plaidé auprès de
vos collègues des finances des comptes
publics pour qu'elle ne soit pas oubliée
dans le futur plan de relance comme nos
jeunes merci messieurs 1
mais monsieur à parle je vais passer là
la parole à monsieur pieds noirs j'ai
passé le relais la présidence d'éléments
d'excusés à monsieur le vice président
la commission parce que j'avais un
conflit d'agenda en toutefois qu'avec
cette anticipé et jeux pour excuse
battement de vos mémos collecte sera
excellemment présidé la fin de cette
séance qui est réservé aux réponses ya
encore deux trois collègues une île et
bien entendu apporter tous les éléments
que nous attendons donc je vais laisser
la place à monsieur le et monsieur pied
noir va d'abord proposer valable dans
son pays grassois et je vais laisser la
place à monsieur pied doit proposer sa
question
merci à la légende d'un sommet sur les
routes et les questions essentielles
évidemment sur le channel c'est sur
l'accompagnement des jeunes notamment
les jeunes diplômés ou viennent d'être
évoqués au bas mot qu'elle avait oublié
par coup et à manger j'ai pas grand
chose à ajouter il ya quand même
un souci sur une épaisseur dans les
concours et examens on a eu l'occasion
évidemment dont discutent et rigoureux
vos collègues du gouvernement a parlé de
génération si ce n'est aux sacrifiés
vraiment une connaissance très vigilants
c'est la naissance en 1728 heureux là où
qui jusque-là +51 tous confondus qui qui
sont qui va arriver dans un marché
l'emploi extrêmement dégradée et de
l'autre côté des entreprises qui
inquiète ne l'ont pas évidemment être
incités contenu grosses économies tôt on
va imaginer
ben je suis pas un grand fan des
solutions ont été avancées par les
collègues pour tout dire on peut
imaginer ne suis pas le plus innovantes
lui allé dire à novatrices pour
concilier tous a offert au sort ont à la
fois on incite les étudiants et les
jeunes à des marchés vraiment je me mets
toi l'assistanat c'est pas trop loin de
notre région et engager les le côté des
entreprises à embaucher ces gens à merci
oui voila voila merci monsieur le
ministre de m'accepter comme relais de
la présidence
je n'ai passé la parole à magali mme
ghali pour une ou deux questions 1 galy
donc
imad el ghali n'est pas là une dernière
question pour jacques grosperrin tu es
là jacques bon s'étaient inscrits tous
les deux voilà ça me soulage pour cette
présidence
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions avant
que monsieur le ministre le balaye
l'ensemble des réponses qui nous ont
apporté je suis là moi tu m'entends jean
pierre qui sait jacques j26 jacques
vas-y il tient donc assez complémentaire
merci jean pierre bonjour monsieur le
ministre
moi je voulais vous a beaucoup de choses
ont été dites mais je voulais vous poser
différentes questions
la première question est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer que le stimulus
évoluer parce que il y à différents
types de modèles y avait un modèle
résilient sur les premiers secours suite
à aux attentats du bataclan et on sait
que le stage de cohésion qui s'appuie
sur de la société on pourrait s'imaginer
suite à ce qui se passe ce qui s'est
passé vous avez de ces pandémies qui est
une nouvelle orientation de ceux de ce
et ses nus parce que nous avons une
population qui est intéressante et on le
voit à ce jour il ya un relâchement très
fort des jeunes ou le bois dans la rue
vis-à-vis de cette pandémie et vis-à-vis
de ceux du confinement et on sait que il
pourrait agir ou interagir à travers les
réseaux sociaux avec sa probation et et
chacun sait qu'on n'apprend plus par ses
pairs que par par ses maîtres
il pourrait aussi peut-être mais c'est
vrai qu'ils sont mineurs intervenir on
peut être accompagnés ou le voit en ce
moment lors des rentrées qui s'effectue
ou 10 minutes lui même la deuxième
question elle rejoint un petit peu et
beaucoup
celle de de jacques bernard magner c'est
l'abondement financier du service
civique par le le service par le sénat
pour l'année 2020 21 dans la mesure où
2019-2020 c'était un peu compliqué pour
coup avec en place parce qu'on voit
véritablement que service civique et
efficace pas simplement pour la ligue
nationale en mai dans la croix rouge
dans les ehpad dans les bibliothèques
mais surtout surtout pour la rentrée
scolaire 2020 2021
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de fort
à faire dans la mesure où on sait qu' il
y aura peut-être une une orientation
vers une première semaine fin août
au niveau des reins
la poche scolaire et puis surtout
d'après mes trimestre scolaire qui sera
complètement différent de ce que nous
avons vécu à ce jour donc on avait
récemment besoin d'un appui fort de
toutes ces personnes qui interviennent
dans le cadre du service civique
merci président le 2 merci merci jacques
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse
répondre à l'ensemble de ces questions
qui doivent qu'ils ont assez volumineuse
b votre esprit de synthèse est bien
connue donc je vous laisse à part merci
monsieur le président je l'étais
vraiment à à tout le monde sans être
trop long ce qui est toujours difficile
mais je vais reprendre les questions et
les unes après les autres voitures
d'oublier personnes et en essayant
d'être plus conciliants possible d'avoir
à l'impérial m'avait interrogé sur le
service civique et la question de la
durée du service
moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
aujourd'hui la durée moyenne du
dispensable x et c'est à dire de moi
c'est pas six mois comme on peut
l'entendre parfois et que moi là dessus
c'est un peu comme le débat qu'on avait
tout à l'heure sur la prolongation à des
missions je pense qu'il faut être
pragmatique il ya des jeunes pour qui il
est justifié que les missions que la
mission soit plus longue que la durée
soit plus longue parce que ils ont
besoin de davantage de temps
il ya des missions pour lesquelles il
est justifié à qu'elle soit plus longue
parce que l'objet de la mission à
nécessite un investissement enduré plus
important pour sa réalisation
et donc il faut savoir s'adapter il ya
des associations je pense notamment à
unis cité qui se sont fixé comme
objectif d'aller chercher des jeunes les
plus éloignés des dispositifs évidemment
pour ces jeunes là et pour l'émission
propose cette association il faut que la
durée soit mais moi je considère pas
qu'il soit nécessaire de donner une
règle finalement unique en termes de
durée pour toutes les missions et pour
tous les jeunes je pense aussi que c'est
important que ça puisse adapter adapté
aux réalités du jeune et de la mission
est en tout cas il n'y a pas de volonté
de brutalement réduire la durée de
toutes les missions et c'est la
démission pour lesquelles s'est justifié
que la durée soit soit réduite mais
c'est pas le cas pour ma ai posé une
question qui est très importante et 13
ak c'est essentiel sur la question du
service civique dans la ruralité c'est
un enjeu qui est très important
et moi ça fait partie de mes objectifs
prioritaires pour développer le service
civique dans les territoires ruraux
il ya plusieurs moyens pour ça d'abord
il ya une mobilisation politique de
notre part et de la part de l' agence du
service civique et c'est ce qui a été
décidé dans la gendarmerie parce que
nous avons décidé de cibler réserver dix
mille missions de service civique
parents à la ruralité c'est un objectif
ambitieux ensuite il ya un enjeu
d'animation territoriale au fond pour
une petite association dans la ruralité
qui a pas l'habitude ça peut être
compliqué d'accueillir un jeune en
service civique s'est débarrassé du
tutorat etc
et là dessus je pense qu'il faut arriver
à accompagner les associations locales
m'emmerde les regroupements par des
collectifs pour accueillir l'ensemble
des jeunes en service civique je dis ça
parce que je les ai vus à l'oeuvre dans
un déplacement que j'ai réalisé il ya
plusieurs mois maintenant
c'était il ya un an déjà dans les
hautes-pyrénées ou gérant j'ai rencontré
les associations qui portait un
collectif qui s'appelle rivage dans le
pays d'adour et donc c'est des
associations assez isolée dans ce
territoire des hautes pyrénées se sont
regroupés au sein d'un collectif pour
accueillir des jeunes en service civique
et les jeunes en service civique sont
accueillis par le collectif lui même et
ensuite il ya disposition des
associations et le collectif associatif
permet de libérer les associations un
certain nombre de formalités et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment pousser ce type de
structure et aller vers cela de plus en
plus dans la ruralité pour permettre aux
associations localement de sans parler
des ce dispositif du service civique
maintenant se poser une autre question
comment est ce que pour les colonies de
vacances nous touchons les enfants qui
en ont le plus besoin qui en fait une
question qu'on va évidemment se poser
très fortement cette année mais dont
nous savons tous que commençons pas nous
la poser cette année puisque elle est
absolument centrale et structurantes sur
le secteur des colonies de vacances je
crois qu'il ya 30 ans il y avait quatre
millions d'enfants qui partait à chaque
année et nous sommes aujourd'hui autour
de 800 milles on voit bien que il ya une
érosion très importante une diminution
très importante du nombre d'enfants qui
part même si l'an dernier c'était
beaucoup mobilisé notamment en termes de
communication il ya eu le premier rebond
dans le nombre d'enfants qui partent
sont partis en colonie de vacances très
faible en à quelques milliers mais on a
mis fin à dix ans où ça déclinait 2
re continue première fois qu'il ya eu un
tir il ya de l'espoir évidemment on
souhaite que cet été on puisse là aussi
par notre mobilisation
il ya je pense que pour toucher donc ses
enfants km a plus d'enfants de partir il
ya plusieurs enjeux il ya un enjeu
financier qui est évident ça coûte de
l'argent d'envoyer ses enfants en
colonie de vacances il ya des
dispositifs de soutien qui existent
notamment via les caisses d'allocations
familiales
il ne touche pas toutes les familles je
crois que c'est jusqu'à un quotient
familial de 800 euros et évidemment il
ya des personnes qui travaillent qui ont
du mal à joindre les deux bouts et pour
qui ça coûte de l'argent d'envoyer en
colo qui ont pas forcément les moyens
comment est ce qu'on arrive à développer
des aides nouvelles et ciblée sur c'est
sur ces familles là il ya un enjeu très
fort aussi d'investissement pour les
associations
et là je vais répondre du coup à une
partie de la question monsieur savant
qui me demandaient si dans le comité
interministériel tourisme de demain
cette question serait abordée je vous
confirme que oui puisque c'est moi qui
rapporte entre guillemets la partie
tourisme social dans ce comité
interministériel et que les prévu visage
et en comité ne s'est pas encore tenu
mais que des mesures financières très
importantes soient annoncés pour
permettre aux associations du tourisme
social et donc notamment à des
associations sports des colonies de
vacances d'investir dans leurs
infrastructures avec un soutien
financier conséquent qui pourrait être
annoncé madame boulet ce dernier vous
m'avez interrogé sur la réserve civile
alors effectivement moi je le dis de
manière très claire c'était une volonté
notre part de réduire le nombre
le mission disponibles en tout cas le
nature des missions disponibles parce
que on était dans une période de
confinement et moi j'étais très
attention à ce qu'il n'y ait pas une
injonction paradoxale à dire aux
français d'un côté restez chez vous et
de l'autre voulait sortir de chez vous à
la moindre occasion pour vous engager et
donc l'objectif de la réserve civique
était moins tournée vers les français
volontaires en se fixant comme objectif
que chaque français qui a envie d'être
utile et de sortir de chez lui pour être
utile puisque le faire mais vraiment
tourner vers les structures et les
associations qui en avait besoin pour
poursuivre leurs activités
d'où le fait qu'il y avait moins de
mission que deux candidats à
encore une fois totalement assumée et
évidemment tous les autres volontaires
qui a été engagée dans une mission en
présentiel
oui la possibilité sur le site de la
réserve cilic de télécharger un kit que
nous avions réalisé avec l'association
voisins solidaires pour s'engager à
l'échelle de leur immeuble à l'échelle
de leur rue pavillonnaire de leur
village avec un annuaire des voisins
avec des dispositifs qui leur permettent
de rentrer en contact avec leurs voisins
pour aller aider une personne âgée une
personne en situation de handicap une
personne vulnérable qui habitent près de
chez eux qu'ils ne connaissaient pas
forcément
et pour lui permettre de s'engager
localement et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que 408 personnes
téléchargez ce kit on voit bien que même
au delà du nombre de personnes qui se
sont inscrites à la réserve cilic et que
l'on a reçu finalement assez peu de
messages de personnes qui s'étaient
inscrites dans la réserve cilic qui
n'étaient pas engagés dans une mission
en présentiel
sans doute parce qu'elles ont trouvé via
ce kit la possibilité de s'engager de se
rendre utile à l'échelle de leur
immeuble de l'heure de leur quartier
pour pour les autres
beaucoup de frustration sur la question
de la pratique sportive
vous avez auditionné je prends ma
collègue roxana maracineanu donc j'ai
pas revenir dans les détails sur le sur
le sur le protocole sanitaire qui est
réalisé et partagé mais il ya un certain
nombre d'associations sportives de clubs
sportifs qui ont pu reprendre ce cadre
de pratiques sportives qui ont pu
reprendre dans le respect d'un protocole
sanitaire ce qui fait évidemment un
certain nombre de pratiques sportives je
pense aux sports bar des sports
collectifs à tous ceux qui appliquent
une proximité ont pu reprendre à ce
stade
d'autres c'est possible évidemment ce
sont les questions sanitaires qui vont
permettre progressivement d'avoir une
reprise de plus en plus large et pour la
prochaine étape du 2 juin évidemment le
souhait est de permettre à davantage de
pratiques sportives et de clubs sportifs
de reprendre leurs activités c'est à ça
qu'on travaille sur la question des
logopèdes orthophoniste et de leur durée
de stage là j'ai pas la réponse là je
n'ai pas à dire autre chose qu'une ne
sais pas mais je m'engage à vous
répondra directement
d'abord parce que je comprends que ça
mange est importante puisque je suis
même intéressé ayant une petite soeur
orthophoniste et donc j'imagine que
c'est un enjeu je vois bien comment
c'est un enjeu important pour les jeunes
étudiants qui
attendre d'être diplômé et donc je vais
je m'engage à vérifier ce point à
revenir vers vous quand vous apportant
des réponses
enfin sur la question du scoutisme c'est
vrai que les passionnés tout à l'heure
alors que travaillons beaucoup avec eux
et vous avez dit que le scoutisme ne
dépend pas d'un état d un peu d pas mais
moi ce que je crois profondément c'est
que l'état a beaucoup à apprendre du
scoutisme et que dans ce que nous allons
proposer deux supplémentaires aux jeunes
cet été mais plus globalement les
évolutions structurantes que nous
pourront pousser dans l'avenir sur un
nombre de ses joueurs qui sont
organisées on a beaucoup à apprendre du
scoutisme parce que c'est des pratiques
innovantes qui ont été portés uniquement
en mouvement anciens qui a gardé
uniquement ses rituels d'antan c'est
aussi des pratiques nouvelles et en
laboratoire pédagogique comme d'autres
associations d'éducation populaire est
ce qu on voit que c'est un mouvement
continue à progresser
il ya assez peu de mouvements
d'éducation populaire le nombre de
jeunes qui est fréquente continue à
avoir à augmenter
c'est le cas pour le quotidien nous
avons beaucoup de choses à développer
avec eux évidemment ils posent beaucoup
de questions sur la possibilité pour eux
d'organiser leur séjour cet été mais
comme tous les organismes et évidemment
nous travaillons avec une pour clarifier
un protocole sanitaire clair
particulièrement difficile pour le
scoutisme
on voit bien les cinq ou six jeunes ou
enfants dans une tente habituellement
pour des raisons distanciation on voit
comment ça parce que je veux vous dire
c'est que ni revenir étroit avec eux que
l'etat sera à leurs côtés pour les
accompagner pour permettre alors séjour
de soutenir parce que beaucoup de jeunes
en moins besoin c'était monsieur karam
vous l'avez interrogé sur la question de
la continuité ans en guyane et et sur
l'application des dispositifs que j'ai a
annoncé que jean michel branquart a
annoncé pour cet été
on dépend aussi beaucoup du choix des
collectivités locales
et s'agissant par exemple des écoles je
crois me souvenir que la collectivité
territoriales de guyane a voté a fait le
choix de allait rouvrir en septembre me
corriger si ça n'est pas le cas donc je
ne suis pas sûr que le dispositif école
ouverte puisque dans ces conditions en
revanche
les accueils de loisirs évidemment
peuvent se tenir et pour les accueils de
loisirs ils s'engageront dans le type de
vacances apprenantes que nous portons
évidemment il y aura un soutien y
compris financier pour les accompagner
moi je souhaite vraiment que puisse se
développer en guide à monsieur ou julias
vous êtes intervenu sur la question des
colonies de vacances moi je le dis je l'
ai dit dès ma nomination il ya un an et
demi moi je souhaite que nous ayons une
vraie politique publique de soutien aux
mouvements d'éducation populaire d'une
manière générale au départ en colonie de
vacances
en particulier nous avions commencé à y
travailler avant cette crise mais cette
crise va peut-être nous permettre de
faire aboutir ce travail que nous avions
engagés sur ce point sur la question
jeudi des investissements des choses
seront annoncées probablement demain sur
la question du soutien au départ des
familles au début du mois de juin dès
lors que sera clarifié la possibilité
vous demande organiser ses colonies de
vacances là aussi des mesures pour moi
être annoncé moi je veux quand même
insisté sur le fait que ces colonies
vacances sont portés par des
associations des acteurs de l'éducation
populaire que je fais attention aussi à
leur autonomie compris pratique
pédagogique qu'elle débloque enfin que
je parle pas je pars que vous avez
mentionné le terme et de services
publics des communes y va quand je pense
que c'est important qu'elles puissent se
reposer sur des acteurs associatifs qui
les font un libre qui évidemment doivent
continuer à être soutenues par les
pouvoirs publics et sur la question vous
évoquez de 2,2 de projet politique qui
est portée dans le cadre de ses vacances
à prenantes
mon souhait qu'il soit le plus partagé
possible et que y compris ça ne soit pas
l'état l'éducation nationale qui
dessinent seul un projet et l'imposante
redit mer au secteur et tout le travail
que nous sommes en train de faire encore
une fois avec ces réunions régulières
avec les principaux acteurs qui ont lieu
au ministère c'est d'élaborer à ce
travail là et si vous souhaitez assister
à l'une de ses réunions et une allait
participer
évidemment tout à fait possible pour
l'organiser au prix avoir un échange
plus nourris sur sur ce que ce que
recoupe n'est pas constamment
monsieur st on m'avait interrogé sur la
question le comité internet à tous et
qui obtient pareil sur le la question du
rebond pour les associations oui moi je
crois profondément que dans la relance
dans leurs gonds pays la vie associative
sera absolument central parce que c'est
ce qui permet du lien social parce que
c'est ce qui permet à une éducation à la
citoyenneté au commun parce que ce sont
aussi des emplois et c'est un secteur
économique je reviendrai sur la question
de la ffs ensuite et donc nous
travaillons à un plan de relance et
associatif avait beaucoup aujourd'hui
trois grandes directions travaux de
l'équipe d'avoir la question de la
sauvegarde et du développement de
l'emploi associatif avec peut-être des
dispositifs de soutien qui ne soit pas
pour autant un retour aux emplois aidés
puisque l'objectif est vraiment de
professionnaliser les associations et
leur permettent de maintenir dans la
durée une capacité à porter les emplois
et pas uniquement être ne pas dépendre
uniquement des cas dans la durée d'un
soutien public on peut imaginer un
soutien à l'emploi dégressif sur
plusieurs années qui permet de faire la
morte et ensuite à l'association veut
développer des ressources propres du
mécénat
ça coince et si c'était l'audition de
gabriella tall secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'éducation nationale il
a tenté de rassurer les sénateurs sur le
soutien de l'état aux associations
le gouvernement va bien maintenir les
subventions aux associations même si les
projets sont annulés les sénateurs sont
en revanche plus sceptique sur le
programme vacances apprenantes le projet
du gouvernement pour organiser des
colonies de vacances éducatives pendant
le mois de juillet et le mois d'août
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi rester informé
sur cette crise sanitaire sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite
une très bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]